corbin byrne one and one in korea in his
career against cincinnati 11 games one
start that one start happened this year
on the road an 8-0 win
over the reds much anticipated series
brewers reds and burns deals a 1-1 swing
of the ground ball got a chance to turn
it woah quick flip over to adamus nicely
turn double play
the reds toss tyler malley tyler malley
his bodywork this year has been very
good he's had 25 starts reds have won 16
of those
got a nice rotation here's a 3-2 and a
dallas pulls one that is going to get
down it's fair
extra basis for adamus
just muscles one down the line
impressively kept it fair though
and it's a one out double
now from the stretch
here it is yellow lines on the left just
like we were talking adamus will be held
at third the throw coming on
and a wise move there by jason lane
reds infield is going to play back and
they'll blame deadpool
jonathan india the second baseman almost
behind second base swinging a fly ball
into
center and deep warning track it's going
to be playable
and caught just missed
but a sac fly willie adams scores and
the crew has the lead
an update from the brewers clubhouse
left quad discomfort for willie adams he
had to leave in the first inning removed
for precautionary reasons the brewers
said so again left quad discomfort
has one strikeout he's given up one hit
two outs in the third india lines one oh
[Music]
makes the play he overran it a bit it
had a little hook on it and uria's had
to hit the deck in order to make the
catch
getting over three up and three down go
the reds
gotta see a held out at first
jonathan india extends and makes the
catch it comes up wincing
clutching at his chest a deep exhale
he has done a little more damage to that
left shoulder we've seen that time and
time again
as he lunges for the ball and he landed
on his left elbow
and you could see the shock factor into
that
right shoulder that left shoulder
double play aided burns erase the lead
off walk in the first
castiano's might have broke his bat
again tried to dig won't fall for that
drops into center and two are on with
nobody out
it was a sinking line drive that fell
for a hit
and the reds have two on with nobody out
and vatto coming up
bottom walks to load the bases and now
mike mustache bats bases loaded
stock is fly to left his first time
nobody out bases full payoff
mustaches throw the whole right side
base in
naquin scores stationed the station
castellano shuts it down in third a
game-tying rbi base knock by mike
mustakas even at one and boy the reds
are really set up here for a big inning
and kyle farmer is coming to the plate
reds have two hits two walks issued by
burns to compound the issue now farmer a
one hop bullet through the left side
that's a base hit castellanos will score
the go ahead run it's 2-1 reds on an rbi
single by kyle farmer
the first five reds have reached against
corbin burns in this fourth inning i go
back to something you said in the first
inning while the brewers were batting no
over swings just nice easy swings
putting the barrel on the ball and
finding holes and that's exactly what
the reds are doing with their three hits
here in the fourth
barnheart center field
kane makes the glove bottle tag from
third throw in fono scores sac fly rbi a
three spot for the reds here in the
fourth inning
strike three call
now he rides the edge that's the fourth
strikeout for the reds right hand what a
pretty pitch right there instead of
going up the ladder went right down at
the bottom of the strike zone
swing at the miss
mustackas rips a line drive into the
right center field alley nobody's going
to get it it's down and all the way to
the wall and mustache is in the second
base standing with a double
i'd say he's starting to get locked in
i would say that ball had some serious
exit velocity
he's receiving a really good game
tonight he's been hitting again of late
1-2
barnhart sprays it into left-center
mustache around third
throw goes to second ustock is scores a
second rbi for tucker barnhart and the
reds lead in milwaukee 4-1 well that was
exactly the same pitch that
he got earlier on and he just stayed
with it it was on the other side of the
plate just came right out there and just
laid the bat head on what a good bit of
hitting by tucker barnhart
a walk in a single with two outs to
bring the tying run to the plate
a hot bat with power in rowdy teles
here's david bell so lorenzen it appears
will be on to face teles
payoff with the runners off
left field aquino
a just late falls down making the catch
he didn't make it look easy but he made
the play
an announcement last week named the
ownership group
back up the middle
kane's got a base hit
three run game lorenzen
deals and pena back up the middle of the
base hit
a little tight line drive for manny pina
back-to-back singles off lorenzo
and the brewers again will bring the
tying run to the plate but this time
back around to the top of the order and
nobody out
many people is really starting to swing
the bat much better fastball middle in
well these fans have been waiting to
roar all game
now colton long up there there's a basin
on the left here comes kane
aquino's throw to the plate and kate is
in there
rbi single
colton wong
it is 4-2 cincinnati three straight hits
in the inning
well colton wong is at his best when
he's thinking left field that was
another fast ball was up
be careful with the cargo giants
the pitch
swing a line drive right center going to
be playable castianos makes the catch
tagging and coming in to score his pina
moving to third is colton wong it's a
one-run game on the sac fly by christian
yelich
and yelich has made this a one-run game
with amazeo garcia coming up
here's the pitch
swinging a line drive left center that's
going to be deep enough to score the run
aquino makes the catch wong tags here
comes the throw home not in time we are
tied
contact indeed sacrifice fly avi garcia
it's a 4-4 game now it is with the
go-ahead run at second base
caravan is trying to add one piece to
the puzzle here
and he pulls one right field that is
down fair
in the score peterson
navier's on his way to second with an
rbi double
5-4 milwaukee
well what an inning
with the order getting it started
a couple of sacrifice flies and a double
by omar narvaez this guy has been money
all year fastball up
able to turn on it
center on it and lines it down the right
field line and the brewers take the lead
with a four spot in the seventh well the
brewers would love to add on right here
oh wrong sends it deep to right and
in the bottom of the eighth it is 7-4
now my goodness how big is that that is
huge
wow
he's coming up with some huge
hits he pops him up that's going to stay
playable
telez makes the call he's got it and the
ball game is over the brewers win
you